And the answer here, I think, is clearly no because a real computer, of course,
has finite memory, but think about your machines.
So let's say you have an older computer like me--so you have 1 gigabyte of memory.
One gigabyte of memory is approximately 1 billion bytes or 8 billion bits.
Now, how many different snapshots can you have with 8 billion bits--that is 2⁸⁰⁰⁰⁰⁰⁰⁰⁰⁰ snapshots.
You wouldn't find a fraction of that as atoms in the universe.
The argument is correct in theory, but it does not have any practical relevance--almost like
the halting problem, which I will soon show you also has actually very little practical relevance,
but for this counter argument, it's basically the same.
For real computer, I think you can consider the memory to be practically infinite.
So this algorithm here just isn't going to cut it unless by real computer,
you mean a very, very, very simple one.